here is a video Trump put this up
yesterday going after DeSantis and again
I like Trump I want to interview him
again I like the kids but listen to this
and tell me the nicknames and the
nonsensical argument he's making here
does any of this make any sense to you
and do you think this is Trump at his
best
for those of you that didn't know notice
Florida was doing great long before
Rhonda Sanctus got there people are
fleeing from New York to Florida and
other places
because of high taxes and out of control
crime it's really bad not because of the
governor thank you Mr President for
doing that
but it's not because of the governor
Florida was doing fantastically you had
a governor named Rick Scott who did a
very good job even Charlie Chris the
Democrat did a good job and he had very
good numbers
sunshine and ocean are very alluring
it's not too hard to work with those
factors
so just remember Florida was doing
really well long before Iran to Sanctus
got there
there's so much here I'm so tired of
this nonsense it's like let me just say
first off Trump again I like you I like
you so if you want to really do this you
just have to level up but this is just a
whole load of nonsense first off Ron
just sank this do you know what Sanctus
means in Latin it means holy okay so I
think you uh failed with that one Trump
and sanctimonious didn't work and okay
the nickname thing it's just not gonna
work because the guy's getting stuff
done it works when you can sort of
needle people on these things it's just
not working on that front uh he's
talking about Charlie Chris there
Charlie Chris just lost by 20 points in
the biggest political destruction really
in modern well certainly in modern times
in Florida but really almost across the
country like Blown Away Charlie Crist
was also a republican Trump is
referencing him as Governor he was
governor what was it like 15 years ago
he was a republican at the time so Trump
is suddenly into rhinos Or democrats
because Charlie Chris became a Democrat
also so uh Rhonda santis
he did do something right which is why
all the people are moving here and we
still get 1200 people a day and AOC and
Eric swalwell and Don Lemon are
vacationing in Florida while they spend
all day long on TV bashing Florida right
so it's just very very bizarre and I
just don't think it works if you want to
beat the guy you have to say these are
why my policies are better but I think
one of the things that Trump is coming
up against is the fact that DeSantis is
actually at the state level doing many
of the things that Trump either said he
was going to do or promise to do and and
just hasn't been able to do really
because he's not in office right now
thank you
[Music]